[Musique]
plus
depuis que nous avons commencé à administrer le
vaccin contre le paludisme en septembre 2019,
nous avons constaté une réduction des cas de
paludisme
et même des enfants qui contractent le paludisme,
ce n'est pas grave
et le nombre de décès dus au paludisme
a également diminué
[Musique]
dale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous réduisez cela de
40,
vous pouvez voir l'impact que cela aura
d'abord sur les familles, ils
n'auront pas à dépenser de l'argent pour aller dans les
établissements de santé qu'ils n'auront pas  doivent
dépenser de l'argent pour acheter des médicaments
ils n'auront pas à dépenser de l'argent pour les
funérailles et aussi pour le
système de santé le nombre d'
enfants arrivant à l'hôpital est
réduit
[Musique]
vous